[Applaudissements]
déjà
tu vas où comme ça j'ai un mariage un
mariage j'ai le mariage de Sarah fraisou
juste après
ce soir faut pas que j'arrive en retard
sinon elle va pas m'inviter à celui de
la semaine prochaine est-ce que tu
connais l'oncle relou généralement c'est
Jean-Michel maire qui quand il te voit
habillé comme ça ça m'arrive à chaque
fois je peux pas les voir ils font eh
alors et tu me sers un truc à boire
horrible c'est vrai non mais c'est
Jean-Michel pourquoi il est magnifique
ça fait plaisir mais non je te jure
c'est vrai c'est sa passion elle se
marie toi c'est le paddle
mariages pour une lune de miel elle peut
le faire toute seule
je lui ai envoyé un message je lui ai
envoyé un message pour son mariage je
lui ai dit félicitations pour ton
mariage à m'envoyer merci mes lequel je
comprends moi je peux la comprendre la
vie et elle veut changer ça arrive c'est
normalement j'ai ce même j'ai ce même
problème en fait moi et des fois il y a
des fils sont belles mais je m'attache à
des détails je comprends je te jure en
ce moment je parle une fille elle est
trop belle mais juste il y a genre elle
m'a elle m'a montré ses pieds en fait
il y en a un autre et tu viens on va
là-bas et le problème c'est qu'à chaque
fois garçon qu'on s'embrouille même si
écoute Ilyes moi je suis droite dans mes
baskets et ça
c'est un problème
j'ai envie de la quitter j'ai du mal à
la quitter je suis un mec je sais pas
comment quitter une meuf je sais pas je
suis panique SMS non mais j'arrive moi
je lui dis c'est fini
moi je lui dis c'est fini elle me
demande pourquoi la vie de ma mère on
reste ensemble c'est fini
je te jure on reste ensemble en tout cas
je suis très content d'être là vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé cette semaine tu
as vu Mbappé comment il parle anglais ah
j'ai vu de ouf comme il parle anglais
Mbappé rien à voir avec le frère de
Pogba
et lui depuis qu'il a parlé anglais tout
part en cacahuète je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué le père de Pogba le frère
de pogbaï a parlé en anglais bon déjà il
est parti en prison c'est pour ça
qu'un jour de deuil en Angleterre c'est
parce qu'il y a pas l'anglais il y a
toujours en équipe de France ils sont
tous blessés c'est parce que
appareillage
d'échange pas comment il va faire je
l'embrasse mais tu vas galérer la vie de
ma mère Didier j'ai hâte de voir la
conférence de presse pour annoncer les
jours de la Coupe du Monde
il sera bloqué ben bonjour à tous
[Rires]
je ne sais pas ou quoi vous annoncez
ils sont tous blessés alors en défense
je vais mettre Anne Hidalgo
pour empêcher la circulation des
défenseurs dans la dans la dans la
surface de réparation Hidalgo c'est la
seule qui va empêcher la circulation on
attaque il ne faut quelqu'un de virulent
Booba
il attaque ses adversaires et tu sais
que tout est parti de Pogba je suis en
train de me dire je pensais ça depuis
qu'il parle en anglais tu pars en
cacahuète et tout est parti d'une
histoire de famille tu te rends compte
moi j'ai plus confiance en mes frères
touche pas mon poste je fais gagner un
peu d'argent je me méfie tout le monde
je suis un nouveau petit frère là
récemment je vous en parle il est tout
petit comme ça il est tout bébé des fois
son nez il coule et tout il me dégoûte
la dernière fois ma mère elle vient elle
me dit mouche-le sauf qu'elle m'a pas
donné un mouchoir Cyril je sais pas si
tu connais elle m'a donné un câble avec
un tube vous connaissez ça la mouche
bébé moi je connaissais pas j'étais un
peu bloqué dans les branchements ma mère
elle vient elle me dit dans le nez dans
la bouche
donc moi je vais dans mon nez je vais
dans sa bouche à lui
elle me dit c'est l'inverse moi j'invers
je suis pas con sauf qu'elle m'a dit un
mot ça m'a traumatisé
sur la vie de ma mère attends
j'ai soufflé moi j'ai soufflé j'ai
soufflé j'ai une grande famille moi j'ai
en fait le problème avec mes frères
c'est qui pourront me racketter comme
Pogba facilement parce que tous mes
petits frères ils sont plus costaud que
moi j'ai aucune crédibilité par rapport
à eux genre là moi j'ai un petit frère à
moi on dirait mon grand frère la
dernière fois je voulais le réveiller
pour qu'il aille à l'école je vais dans
sa chambre je toc j'ai tu te réveilles
tu vas à l'école il m'a dit je fais pas
à l'école il y a quoi
merci
[Applaudissements]